hi missus be gentle and I'm a writer
director producer and self fund OBS
court a feature chronicling gender
perception within society by way of the
sex industry now today I'm here to talk
to you about five problems I faced but
making the escort the trials and
tribulations we encountered what it
would mean for production and how he
overcame them but before I do so I dice
take a brief moment to recap the journey
and explain how he got to this point now
my foes of you watching I'm an avid fan
of film molded by it living it leaving
it dependent on it and after writing my
first feature screen clear the age of 12
I knew that was what I wanted to do with
my life I've spent almost every day
students revising or Tinker English
scripts made my first Papa short in 2008
for the film called ticket about toxic
masculinity and earned my first
producing credit that same year with fix
a feature about drugs starring Olivia
Wilde
then after I continued to rise as later
projects and honed my craft to the
course a train dance and volunteered to
shoot corporate videos for free in order
to try out different styles leasing with
someone I know productions designed the
Chancellor going on a TV series always
developing finally I formed a production
company Phoenix Waters productions in
2015 in order to bring my stories to
life tell of different genres amassed
over a decade all high concepts dealing
with person and social themes and the
first feature I wanted to make was vs
sport now I had no funding in place but
I knew this story was special and the
right features of you so I said to money
aside for my day job the fungus film
spent several months interviewing
current and former sex workers to lend
credence to the script it was important
to me that their views be echo with
enmity stealer characters words
well event my assumptions wrote the
screenplay with budget constraints in
mind two characters one location and
spoke of an accomplished female director
about humming the projects but it's
blowing the escort industry wasn't of
interest to her and so I made the
decision that this would be my feature
directorial debut as well cut to almost
three years later and the escort is
about to claim you in New York at the
Kew Gardens Festival of cinema reaction
from those who've seen it has been
immensely positive distribute is always
amazing offers the company now has an
exceptional board
and I'm busy prepping my next feature 95
bod foes for years weren't easy
and so without further ado here are five
problems I faced when filming the escort
a nine-day shoot actor Kevin Leslie case
looks like Eric in the movie and does a
phenomenal job in the world
Kevin however had other film commitments
at the time which meant he only had 19
days to shoot a feature because on day
10 who is have to shave his head for a
role and noting the install takes place
in real time there would have been
glaring continuity errors I didn't want
to slap him with a Kate mallet fantastic
for wig plus I didn't have a budget for
one now we had one month between costing
all the vehicles as a title character
it's to handle again budget constraints
and shooting the film as I was still
finalizing my crew and searching for the
right location to keep an option cost
though so I went to studio room in a
wolf but by accident I would work on
refining the characters farewelled
and the execution of their dialogue at a
very specific approach in mind the
actors continue to really hurt
themselves even the studio or on skype
and I went for the script listing every
shot I wanted please note I could have
owned only afford one camera so who a
lot of retakes as it was important not
to keep the action static that way I
could keep production efficient and
ensure we were moving at pace during the
shoot the camera operator DP and I would
hold a meeting every morning on the
train to discuss shots we needed
whatever evening the actors would
rehearse for the next day while I would
sleep at 2 a.m. each night and wake up
at 3:30 to prepare for the following day
shoot and kudos to the cost there was
one scene for instance in the kitchen
way was important to accomplish it in
one take which was a challenge for all
noting the technical requirements but
especially for them as was a lot of
dialogue and they couldn't afford the
flop line everyone was passionate
everyone was involved a number last day
we shot for 17 hours straight in order
to complete the film
culminating in our shooting the bedroom
scene which was the trickiest and most
emotional one to do fortunately morale
was intact
which is the key to success for any
production or venture to a war zone next
door if I could make any change to be
escort it would be shoes at a different
location not because of the location
itself which I'm grateful to have been
offered
or because of a poverty next door which
sounded like a microbe a blockbuster to
explain quiet in the shoot I was advised
building works would be completed by the
time principal photography began at last
them we arrived on set we found this
wasn't the case and had to battle our
way for the sales or power drills saws
and heavy machinery for iteration of a
shoot
well the builders were adamant we were
very short a porn film and never even
taught him a title ultimately it was a
lot of negotiating involved and I would
frequently visit the house to arrange
time stops of silence or ask for a
specific amount of time to get a take
right whilst we also tried to use that
time to stay productive when it was
noisy who shoot b roll footage or take
lunch so we could shoot when they're on
break and during an off-screen monologue
where the camera needed to focus on the
listeners reaction we decided to shoot
for scene and we record from a login
post now not everything was sorted this
way but bathroom scene which was shot
perfectly had it sound butchered but
thanks to ADR worked by Phil Clemens and
a positive relationship of a builder's
next door we were able to get through it
and the final track is a testament to
this and he doesn't look or sounds like
we faced these problems
fully a change of DP well the director
has a vision but director of photography
is imperative to the execution of our
vision and so the looks style and feel
of a film would have been discussed long
in advance and the DP perceives it from
a technical standpoint their star much
like for directors permeates in each
production from Davis kanji and Conrad
I'll hold to Robert Richardson and Roger
Deakins when the original DP needed to
leave production early for personal
reasons this threatened to derail the
plan we had in place I was conscious at
this would distract for cost and clue as
I needed him focus and giving their all
particularly the actors who had some
challenging scenes to perform so we
agreed to keep this news from them on to
the replacement was found we have a DP
continuing till the end of the week
during each break from filming I would
leave a house to make cause in an effort
to find someone on such short notice
and fortunately believe he introduced me
to someone both butchered James a
Steadicam operator who agreed to step
into the DP role in order to keep
production on track the other problem
was style as their visual language will
be different to each other but
fortunately my intent had always been
but every scene would be shot in a
subtly different way to affect the story
and characters in that moment so how
many different styles fit with the
context that was always trying to do as
long and it was a radically different
and Bo work tirelessly along with camera
operator Stewart are that you off to put
in extra days to give a look at the
shots I envisage now we had a
transitional period as he moved from one
DB to the next and because of this
production stayed on track and we
crafted some of the finest moments in
the film from the dolls dance scenes
four bedroom with our new addition to
the team
for freakish winds and rain during a
supposedly sunny outdoor shoot the
escort takes place in real time and he
was important to me but he bit set
during the day since night time i shady
activities tend to be synonymous with
each other and i wants to underline the
activities that go on in quiet pleasant
neighborhoods on seemingly bright days
we had said one morning to shoot all the
outdoor scenes based on the schedule we
had in place and the weather forecast
but unfortunately in one of the
freakiest moments of a shoot that
morning was met with high winds and
light rain that meant Kevin's clothes
are flapping about in the wind and their
- almost shouted their lines to be heard
the equipment has all been moved outside
of his shoots
prepping a different scene as shooting
inside we have taken at least an hour
and I knew based on my schedule about
shooting it on a different day we'd have
sacrificed all my time on other more
technical and emotionally challenging
scenes this is why I posed a question to
you what would you do in our case both
Stewart and I rated him a mini hobby
Kane outside until there was a brief
moment when the winds and rain subsided
and we were able to shoot the scene but
we were extraordinarily fortunate to get
it
so I'd be keen to hear your thoughts 5
losing the climax of act 1 if there is
one piece of advice I would give anyone
is to have a good day to rank them in
what was the biggest shock during the
production we lost the climax of act 1
not just for your vision about the
backup leading to a subsequently forming
multiple backups for rest of production
one take remained intact but he's only
showed one of the actors and we knew we
had no choice but to reshoot say for a
brief flirtation of having it done anime
style but it was something we avoided we
prepped to shoot five months later when
Kevin had grown his hair but we no
longer had access to the location and
had to shoot in Liverpool Street now
this poses its own challenges because
it's clear that we shoot in a different
location and consider not be able to
escorts apartment this would be a
problem
no we looked at various options maybe
we'd have a blowout of a background and
just shoot it there oh boy I ultimately
decided to do was to have the plops I'm
a set and most importantly four so far
since that's where calcloud miss
Franklin takes place bring that over to
Marzette and film in innovate tight mana
I would focus on the characters faces
this actually works ideally for us
because looking at the scene and what
was occurring there was an argument and
we were looking to break them apart
some of from a visual standpoint we
thought why not just have them not share
the scene now the problems even been
that week so two days before were due to
shoot the film I had a personal issue
my mother was diagnosed with cancer but
this was important that we keep it quiet
from the cast and crew again because I
need them to focus on the scene I needed
an event to focus and give it that board
it was an emotional scene it was an
important scene to do and so I worked at
them I kept these personal things
private and we were able to shoot the
scene we work afterwards who editing
enabled us to you to
I've seen that we had that one take that
we had in my location with what we
created afterwards and fortunately it
meshed well it worked well and I'm
really proud and happy with what we've
created so those are five problems I
faced making the escort and I hope you
never have faced boats during your
production and ultimately thank you very
much for your time I hope this was an
educational one and I wish you best of
luck with your films Thanks